en este vídeo haremos algunos ejemplos
para evaluar expresiones con integrales
definidas y bueno en este caso tenemos
la integral definidas que va de menos 2
a 3 de la función 2 f x de x más la
integral definida que va de 3 a 7 de la
función 3 f x de x y lo que sabemos de
fx es esta gráfica de ye igual a fx que
va desde x igual a menos seis hasta x
igual a 7 y también nos dan las áreas
bajo la curva que hay entre la fx y el
eje x y miren el área negativa nos
muestra que la función está por debajo
del eje x entonces conociendo esto cómo
podemos evaluar la expresión los invito
a que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
intentarlo por su cuenta ok lo primero
que necesitamos hacer es que vamos a
tomar estas constantes y vamos a
sacarlas de la integral porque 1
a veces que la saquemos nos quedaremos
solamente con las integrales definidas
de fx y eso lo podemos relacionar con
las áreas que tenemos aquí
esa es una propiedad de las integrales
muy común y se puede aplicar tanto a
integrales definidas como indefinidos
entonces por ejemplo si tenemos la
integral de k fx de x esto es lo mismo
que acá por la integral de fx de x
entonces apliquemos esa propiedad vamos
a sacar el escalar de la integral y nos
queda que esto es lo mismo que 2 por la
integral definida que va de menos 2 a 3
de fx de x más 3 por la integral
definida que va de 3 a 7 de fx de x
ok vamos a ver esto que será la integral
definida que va de menos 2 a 3 de fx de
x bueno esto lo podemos ver como el área
que hay entre igual a fx y el eje x
desde x igual a menos 2 hasta x igual a
3 entonces desde x igual a menos 2 hasta
x 3 tenemos esta área entre ye igual a
fx y el eje x y nos dicen que es igual a
7 entonces esto es igual a 7 y después
tenemos la integral que va de 3 a 7 de
fx entonces si vamos de 3 a 7 bueno esto
tendrá un valor negativo porque fx se
encuentra por debajo del eje x por eso
tiene un valor de menos 3
entonces nos queda que esto es igual a 2
por 7 que es igual a 14
3 x menos 3 que es igual a menos 9 y 14
- 9 es igual a 5 ok esto es divertido
hagamos otro aquí tenemos la integral
definida que va de 0 a 5 de fx de x
entonces para este caso si va de 0 a 5
de 0 a 5 estamos hablando de esta área
que nos dicen que es igual a 4 4 fue
fácil y a eso le vamos a restar la
integral definida que va de menos 8 a
menos cuatro dedos fx bueno para esta
parte primero necesitamos sacar el 2 de
la integral
entonces si sacamos el 2 de la integral
que va de menos 8 a menos 4 de fx
entonces esto es igual a 2 por 5 porque
corresponde a esta área así que al
simplificar nos queda como 4 menos el 2
que sacamos de la integral menos 2
5 y eso es igual a vamos a ver 4 - 10 es
igual a menos 6 hagamos uno más aquí
tenemos la integral definida que va de
menos 7 a menos 5 entonces si va de
menos 7 a menos 5 que se encuentra
aproximadamente por aquí necesitamos
encontrar esta área esa área y después
tenemos una integral que va de menos 5 a
0 entonces esta parte va de menos 5 a 0
corresponde a todo esto ahora hay dos
formas en las que podemos resolver esto
una forma y suponiendo que existe alguna
simetría aquí no nos lo dicen pero se ve
muy simétrico aproximadamente en x igual
a menos 5 entonces podemos suponer que
este 8 se divide en estas dos regiones
pero una forma más sencilla de
resolverlo es simplemente dándonos
cuenta de que si pasamos de menos 7 a
menos 5 y después de menos 5 a 0 como
estamos integrando lo mismo es decir fx
de x entonces podemos reescribir las dos
integrales como la integral definida que
va de menos 7 hasta 0 de fx de x así que
en realidad como estamos hablando del
área neta que hay de menos 7 a 0 esto es
igual a 8 positivo y después tenemos
menos 1 entonces menos 1 esto es igual a